welcome to one of the safest labor seats
in Britain there's a statue to former
Prime Minister Harold Wilson here
positioned between the pound stretcher
and the post office but people here
won't have a say in who the next prime
minister is but in the coffee shop on
the high street there's a sign that
political views here aren't so close
though Leslie and her brother Paul are
having coffee there yeast of old labor
would have been turned virus Johnson is
stronger stronger person but I hope and
that what he says it's going to pull off
it's one that I don't be done about all
the people don't have a say in the
factor who should be the next prime
minister for the Tories you know it's
wrong and my fault it will be for black
there Johnston was Johnson yet is it
actually gonna put action into it
because that's where it's lying in all
the Cotton's what do you think he will I
don't know it's hard to say something
you're willing to put all of your faith
in him but I would put my faith in them
just to see just a test and to see how
far he goes is it blind faith I think it
could be Boris Johnson isn't so popular
elsewhere in this city Liverpool he once
wrote is a self pity city referencing
the grief displayed after Hillsborough
the elected mayor of Liverpool Joe
Anderson is watching the leadership
contest very closely I look at that
field and you know if that was somebody
that was going to take over run and you
know one of our major companies would be
seriously scared about whether they have
the ability to do it regardless of what
you think about his policies and his
views Boris is a personality he's a
character people are craving that that's
something that your party hasn't
currently got mr. bean was popular and
he was a buffoon and people could see
through that and they'll see through
that with Boris the business world is
getting twitchy though especially
fledgling ones this startup in knowsley
makes a device that melts medical
needles for better more hygienic
disposal a good brexit deal they'll stay
in the UK a bad one they'll move to
another country so this company needs
stability certainty and strong
leadership do you do you think we're
going to get that
I told trust any of the politicians we
have got what we've got and I think the
to London's eccentric but I just need
someone to make a decision and say we're
out no deal or we're out with a deal but
the limbic stage is no good we can't
plan while we don't know what's going on
if the Beatles represented anything it
was popularity and while that might be
enough to win the leadership it may
require more substance to succeed at it
Nick Martin Sky News Liverpool